possible but this is not a responsible
package thank you thank you
Oh
it's like the old days we continue now
with our c-span coverage of events
surrounding the House Senate
negotiations on the federal budget next
we will hear from US representatives
calling themselves the Progressive
Caucus the members met with President
Clinton at the White House this morning
to express their concerns about the
federal budget bill members of this
group say they are looking out for the
interests of the quote working people
and the poor following their meeting
with the president the members met with
reporters outside the White House to
explain their cause this 10 minute
briefing begins with representative
Bernard Sanders an independent member of
Congress from Vermont what we had is a
very good conversation with the
President and the Vice President talking
about some aspects of the budget
reconciliation bill that we feel
strongly about some problems that we
have with it and some ideas that we have
for the future in which we would like to
work with the president specifically one
of the elements of this program that all
of us feel very positive about is that
after years and years in which the rich
grew much richer and their tax burden
went down at the same time as working
people and poor people group or and
their tax burden went up we all feel
very positive that it is about time and
we're delighted that the president has
come forward and said the rich have got
a slight start paying their fair share
of taxes and that some of that money are
not insignificant some 21 billion is
going to the Earned Income Tax Credit
which is going to lower taxes for the
working poor rich are going to start
paying more working people are going to
start paying less and many of us feel
very positive about that also we feel
very positive although we would have
liked more and will fight for more that
for the first time in many many years a
president is beginning to pay attention
to the needs of the children of this
country it is a national disgrace that
we have x double the highest rate of
poverty in the industrialized world for
our children so we feel good that not
only will the Earned Income Tax Credit
be there but the food stamp program is
going to be expanded the children's
immunization program is going to be
expanded the family preservation act
which deals with child abuse is also
going to be adequately funded so they're
elements of the program that we feel
very positive about some that we don't
feel so positively about for example
some of us all of us I think believe
that the corporate income tax should
have gone up to thirty six percent in
our districts people are not moaning the
fact that the rich are not paying more
we think that they should so we think
that there's some very strong
initiatives here in some areas we think
that perhaps we should have gone further
well at 21 billion dollars let's not kid
ourselves this is the strongest
anti-poverty program to be brought forth
in this country in the last 20 years and
what is being said is that while we ask
the rich to finally stop paying their
fair share of taxes a significant amount
of that money is going back to people
today for making four bucks an hour for
in a quarter an hour five dollars an
hour 6,000 hour and they have kids so
all of us I think without exception feel
very positive that the Earned Income Tax
Credit is a significant way to go
forward to deal with poverty in America
and especially with children's poverty
well and also the Earned Income Tax
Credit means that working people will
not have to go on programs that are
costing a great deal they will in fact
be lifted out of their poverty and work
with pride and live with pride and they
will be contributing to the economy and
we're very pleased with that the
president got your boats at this point I
think I don't know that we want to be
definitive about this I think what we
want to see is what the end of the
package looks like now we met with
Speaker Foley just the other day to
express very strong concern that when
the gas tax went down from 6.5 cents the
4.3 12 billion dollars were lost and
what we said to the speaker and I think
reiterated in general to the President
and Vice President is don't take that
money out of the needs of working people
and the children of America and
obviously we haven't seen the final
package yet so I think we're going to be
a little bit reluctant to give you a
definitive answer to that question
genetic element analysis both I think I
don't say I want to speak for other
people but I think Henry Waxman is
absolutely right to raise concerns that
is not the best way to get the revenue
and what we certainly hope is that that
money will come from the doctors and
hospitals and not from the needs of our
senior citizens who wear today hurting
very badly we didn't talk about specific
promises one of the issues i should say
that many of us raised was a need for a
jobs bill that is many positive things
as there are in this program but there
still is not is a significant jobs ville
it puts millions of American people to
work so I think almost all of us feel
that that should be coming down the pike
fairly soon we would like that and I
think the president gave some indication
he's willing to take a look at that well
for the present and for the future but
we did raise future issues and the jobs
bill I mean ultimately we still have 16
million workers in this country or
unemployed or underemployed and they
want us and I think the president wants
to put those people back to work we lost
a 16 billion dollar job program many of
us believe that that was not handled
well that we did not do a good job the
President did not do a good job and that
if we could take the case to the people
that we can rebuild America and put
people back to work we think we have not
only an important step forward but a
winning political program well I think
he indicated that it's something he's
gonna be thinking about
stimulus package next pack well again I
don't want to speak to everybody but I
think all of us in terms of the
democratic process that you have one
senator who is able to hold hostage an
entire program supported or lean or
which hundreds of people are leaning
toward is a real problem thought I think
I speak for most people about that
stimulus package my diq possible next
year when the agenda is I don't want to
put words in his mouth I really don't
like doing that but i think we impressed
upon him the importance of that and I
think he's willing to give that some
serious court well I think what many of
us felt is we're not going to go tell
you that the Congress is a particularly
progressive institution but we did think
that there were more progressives in the
Congress then the White House of the
American people really knew of so we
reached out and we brought people
together to concentrate on a progressive
agenda that reflects the needs of
working people and poor people now what
we are also aware of is that the
conservative caucus if you like has had
a whole lot of clout Charlie Steinem has
done a very good job in taking this
country in the Congress to the right and
some of us thought it's appropriate that
if we split up and then the Black Hawk
is the Women's Caucus this panic or cos
the Progressive Caucus we might begin to
fight for the rights of working people
and move the agenda a poet a little bit
more progressive way forgive me I had
something unwanted you organized this
was organized about two years ago oh
there is yeah I'd like to add that
without the voice of the Progressive
Caucus and the Hispanic and black caucus
and the Women's Caucus we would not be
nearly as close as we are to our
original goals for investing in
humankind in this country our voice was
heard and it'll be continued to be heard
of we could have lost the whole thing
our president is for our programs but he
needed our voice and he got it and we've
come a long way
oh I think we came away with a whole
life I mean during the last week we have
met with mr. Foley mr. Panetta and today
the President and the Vice President to
make it very clear what our agenda is
that is don't forget the needs of
working people the poor the children of
America and I think that word is getting
out very very clearly it's not just
corporate America that we got to worry
about got to worry about the needs of
ordinary people no I think on that issue
without going into great detail today
there are probably some very serious
disagreements between many of us I don't
want to speak for the people yes many of
us of a single-payer many of us are
auntie NAFTA nuts initial we did not get
into they're going to pay more taxes but
my job is not to worry about then we got
hungry children in my state who need to
be fed we have working people who need
jobs and frankly after 12 years of
reaganomics in which hundreds of
billions of dollars was shifted from the
pockets of working people and poor
people to the rich you know we have the
widest gap between the rich and the poor
in the industrialized world so I don't
think our job is to worry about the
needs of the Rick somebody's got to
stand up for working people in this
country well again I don't like I don't
think we like putting words in somebody
else's mouth I don't think that that's a
concept that is alien to him I'd like to
say something about the meeting I'm
congressman pelosi from San Francisco
and during the campaign President
Clinton said that working families in
America should not live below the
poverty level in this package the
president took the leadership to put the
Earned Income Tax Credit in a very
strong number it will be in the bills we
understand it now at 21 billion dollars
in putting that money in their president
clinton honored his commitment to
working families in our country and kept
his promise to children that if their
families work full time they would have
they wouldn't live below the poverty
line we wanted to give our support to
the president to hold the line that that
number did not go below 21 billion our
colleague cynthia mckinney also was very
forceful and having single of employers
and employees excuse me in the bill
which affected families in America as
well so we consider this a great victory
and at why we're on it it also helps
businesses because many of the people in
America who are working at the minimum
wage are working below the poverty line
at some point we must increase the
minimum wage the economy might not be
able to take it right now they tell us
but this is a way to help families
living in poverty and small businesses
in America and the president helped the
president keep his promise to keep
people first absolutely okay Pelosi is
there enough votes in the house right
now I believe that the house will pass
the president's program it was about
Rosie I'm a coffee well the president
has been very generous with his time and
informing members of why certain things
are in the package I think he's worked
very hard when we win in the house it
will be